uh interestingly the obi-wan kenobi your  braid  that you wore in the first films it was  recently up for auction  now it doesn't it looks slightly less  impressive not attached to your head  this is this is how it appeared in the  auction cap  now good game good game shirley ballas  how much did that braid of hair go for  50 000 okay oh how much  don't you no you can't answer yet don't  have to oh yeah uh ashley what do you  think oh um 51 000.  okay uh frank you are a star wars fan  how much would you pay for i am and i  don't want to go lower in case you and  he's deeply offended i'm gonna say  28 grand yeah i went for three uh  no not three dollars three thousand  three thousand  i would say that would have been three  dollars would have been really rude no  three thousand  i was thinking what i would pay oh yeah  all right uh euro mcgregor it's uh  lovely thank you for taking time out of  your filming to come and talk to us  and uh hopefully we'll see you soon  [Music]  you